well part of the argument comes back at
me and I guess I have sort of been one
of the more outspoken individuals is
there more people watching baseball than
ever before it doesn't make it right
just remember Taylor Hooton son I mean
excuse me let's remember dawn hooting
son Taylor when we appeared in Congress
two or three families who lost kids to
anabolic steroids you know I often say
when it comes to the Players Association
who looks out for the good welfare of
their players they should know should
not only be looking out for the
financial good welfare of their players
but their health good and welfare of
their players season the consequences of
these drugs are not inconsequential just
look what happened to professional
wrestling in the number of premature
deaths which we think can't prove of
pretty comfortable related to the abuse
of anabolic steroids and human growth
we're alone so what's it going to take I
don't know I mean we have many of us
have laid out the elements you know it's
not like they have to invent the program
it exists they just have to read it and
implement it will get a third party to
implement it the you know changing the
ones changes within their program is not
work gonna change anything but that's
what they're at that's where they're at
so I don't know the answer I don't know
if they ever will until such time as
public opinion puts enough pressure on
them and right now public opinion is
intrigued you know does this record
count doesn't a crown just did this guy
take it or didn't they take it you know
these home runs worth your being in the
whole thing we're not being in the whole
thing all those kinds of things people
that seem to be more interested in those
debates as I go around then gee what's
the consequences of all of this
I got an innocent so this as a physician
and watched what's happened to people
it's quite distressing